Chuyên quên nha đồng loa lấy tiếng phản đối xong khi Mỹ tiếng ánh không kích bà cơ sở hành nhân quan trọng của Yiran bao dọ sáng ngày 20.
Nãy gạo đảng dân chủ thử dân ngay ông Leonis Lowski Cánh báo,
hành động này có thể đưa thế giới vòng nguy cơ thể chiến thư bà.
Ông trời rằng Washington đã leo thang thẳng thẳng mạc không có lý dọ quân sự, hay pháp lý dọ sản.
Phó chỗ tịch khuổi đồng ánh đi ngà đi midi mì chỉ mấy phía đáp cũng nhận định.
Tổng thống Trump đã khởi đọng một cuộc chiến mới, tránh ngược khoảng tuàn với ngành tổng thống vì khoa bình.
Chúng khi đó, hơi phân ngôn điện kế bình nhận mạnh chục đồng đần tiến xán bầu vực chiến tranh
về điều này đe dọa tự án điện của ngà.
Ông sẽ gây là bró bộ trường ngoại giống anh ấy.
Nhưng người tiếng rằng Isoran có khuyện từ vệ nhưng từ vệ khỏi cách gì.
Nếu các khuôn xan sĩnh sạch quyền từ vệ là tự quy định mà không quan tâm đến hiểm chương.
Thì sẽ không còn trực tự thị dưới nước án mà chỉ có sự hỗn lợt hoàn toàn.
Như tổng thống ngà đã nói nhìn không ngay thế chính thương bà có thể sắp sĩ ra.
Bông ngoại giống ngà kia của hội đồng bà lên quân và cơ quan năng lượng quân từ của tệ IIA.
Lên tiếng về cuộc không kích đồng thời yêu cầu Isoran chấm rất khai đồng quân sử.
Tổng thống rất là đi nghiêm của chiến cho biết ngà đã đề xuất thức sải pháp bảo đảm ảnh khu vực.
Kuyến kích lối thoại và ngăn chạp liệu thằng xúc đồng.